vous avez travaillé à la mine vous
voulez me parler de cette expérience
et parce que la maison on était beaucoup
d'enfants 14 enfants alors papa était
mutilé de guerre on avait pas beaucoup
d'argent c'était la guerre alors qu'on
n'avait pas on pouvait pas aller
travailler au père alors maman elle m'a
fait rembrancher à la mine et j'ai
commencé à 14 ans parce que j'avais déjà
mes frères et soeurs qui y travaillaient
aussi la mine
et il faut les dessous alors
pour nourrir toute la famille parce que
on était beaucoup d'enfants
étaient à la mine
les plus vieux oui enfin les deux
dernières défis qu'ils n'ont pas été
mais tous les autres les garçons et les
filles il y avait cette fille cette
garçon et tous les autres ils ont été à
la mine ils ont travaillé que les deux
plus jeunes défis qu'ils n'ont pas été
mais les autres ils ont travaillé tous à
la mine aussi une fillette de qu'est-ce
qu'elle faisait à la nuit
des fois on faisait même l'ouvrage d'un
homme parce que au début on triait les
cailloux ont tirer les cailloux des
cahiers alors on était devant une sorte
de toile et le les cailloux puis les
Gayet il passe en même temps alors il
fallait retirer les cailloux puis
seulement laisser aller les gaillettes
pour qu'ils aillent d'avoir alors les
GTA terre les cailloux puis alors il y
avait quelqu'un d'autre qui ramassait
avec une pelle qui les mettait dans un
bar où alors là de là on a les mettre
dans une berline
et on faisait aussi bien c'était du
dégommer parce que
de même des grands gamins parce que les
grands gamins on les envoyer au molinage
alors comme nous qu'on était là c'était
l'ouvrage des gamins qu'on faisait aussi
bien que
que pour t'envoyer quoi que des hommes
même parce que des fois c'était très dur
on arrivait pas à pousser le
le moins cher la petite barreau on
appelait ça barreau c'était mais alors
des fois il fallait être à deux pour le
pousser
je sais plus mais en face c'est que
c'était lourd combien que je peux
pousser
c'est pas
dans quelles conditions
surtout pendant la guerre c'était
pendant des bonnes conditions la
premièrement on avait pas des habits
pour parce que c'était la guerre on
n'est pas des bons habits on n'avait pas
des bonnes chaussures on n'avait pas des
à manger on avait pas bien à manger non
plus parce que en ce moment là il y
avait pas
rien du tout alors des fois même on s'en
allait travailler avec des pommes de
terre cuites à l'eau
parce que on n'avait pas de pain perdu
tout c'était avec des tickets qu'on
avait du pincement alors quand il y en
avait ça allait mais que des fois il y
avait pas de temps on mangeait des
pommes de terre avec des pommes de terre
et vous travaillez combien d'heures par
jour
on partait moi je partais travailler en
5 heures malcar parce que je donnais les
lampes au mineur avant des
gris-blard donner les lampes alors après
je l'ai au gris blanc on commence à 6h
et demi deux heures moins le quart enfin
[Musique]
jusqu'en 49 je me suis marié en 48 ans
je travaille encore ah oui j'ai
travaillé peut-être encore 7 mois après
que je me suis marié
et à la mine alors là j'étais plus
horrible quand j'ai été marié j'étais au
à la lampe quand
on faisait les lampes lumineux pourquoi
les jeunes filles qui peuvent travailler
au criblage ah non les gars
c'est quand on est marié quand on est
marié
en ce moment-là les femmes mariées ils
travaillaient pas au gris blanc
après si parce que quand on est arrivé
ici dans le nord c'était des femmes
mariées qui travaillaient tandis que
nous non les femmes mariées elles
avaient une place dans la cour quoi
plutôt c'était plutôt dans le gris bas
c'était des jeunes filles et des jeunes
hommes enfin des gamins parce que quand
ils étaient jeune homme quand ils
avaient casse 16 ans ils montaient des
jambes des gamins et c'était rien que
des filles qu'ils étaient au gris
blanche c'est à dire que il y avait même
enfin il y en a une qui est restée en
étant marié parce qu'elle a pas voulu
aller travailler elle pouvait pas
travailler dans l'eau
et après la pisterie ça lui plaisait
pour elle avait resté au griblage mais
autrement une préférez pas avoir des
femmes mariées horribles
Caro tout ça
il voulait pas
vous avez posé
il travaille à la même force que moi
il travaille au fond bien sûr
pas beaucoup pour beaucoup de temps il
doit monter tout de suite au moulinage
puis après il y a des voiles
on s'est connu dans des réunions après
deux jeunes là qu'on faisait et puis on
s'est connu enfin ce qu'on essaie déjà
mais parce qu'on essaie de la force
on se marie
en 48 la première semaine de la grande
grève de 48
[Rires]
[Musique]
on n'a pas eu aussi par quoi ça reposé
de moi
c'est ce qui nous aurait été malheureux
pour nous parce qu'en travaillant en
deux
c'est du repos sans être du repos parce
que on faisait le piquet de greffe il
fallait manifester tout partout en
Béthune
on se faisait des fois attraper par les
CRS il y a même des camarades qui ont
été en prison par les CRS qui étaient
commandés à ce moment-là par
je suis le mot qu'on fasse pas super
mais c'est la vérité alors je peux le
dire et même les l'armée qu'ils ont venu
avec des Sénégalais pour essayer
enfin des fois
elles participaient à la grève
tous ceux qui travaillaient même les
femmes aiment les femmes des mineurs et
venaient aussi à la porte parce que là
c'était nous qui occupait le carême le
carreau de Minnie c'était nous qui était
dedans alors on était dans les bureaux
on se faisait ma chance réchauffer là
mais on passait nos nuits à la force et
après quand il y avait des
manifestations bah aussi bah tous les
femmes il allait aussi bien que les
hommes en ce moment-là c'était même plus
que maintenant que les piquets de grève
c'était tout le monde qu'il y allait
c'était des routes manifestations
d'ailleurs je me rappelle à Béthune
quand on est arrivé de tous les quads
Béthune
il y en a vite tout partout qu'ils
arrivaient hein après on s'est sauvé
parce que les CRS ils ont arrivés aussi
alors il y en a beaucoup qui ont été
ramassées même qui ont été à la prison
Béthune
[Musique]
des mineurs
alors vous pouvez nous dire pourquoi
vous quittiez originaire du
Pas-de-Calais vous vous retrouvez ici à
Sabatier c'est parce que quand
on s'est marié bon on avait une maison
on a vu la première fois qu'on a une
maison c'était une pièce partagée en
deux bon après quand que j'ai eu le
deuxième gamin on a fait la demande
d'avoir une plus grande maison et alors
là la maison c'était pour aller au water
il faut aller faire bientôt 50 mètres
pour y aller alors donc
on a quand même resté là mais dans ce
coin-là on avait fait la demande pour
avoir une plus grande maison et parce
qu'on avait su que les mineurs parce que
tel contrer tel coin de
bar là mais t'aurais
vous savez il devait partir être
mutuelle alors nous on avait fait la
demande pour avoir une plus grande
maison dans la dans une autre cité et on
a été refusé parce que eux ils savaient
que les mineurs ils allaient être
muttérieurs alors du coup on a dû rester
là et puis il a été
alors au début partir avec ultra alors
au travail du tout alors ils avaient
froid puis partaient assez de bonheur au
matin et revenir à cette heure dans
l'après-midi et puis comme ils avaient
froid tout seul alors une fois c'est
décidé on était trouvé le directeur de
force on a monté dans le train avec eux
puis on a été trouvé le directeur puis
on lui a dit que c'était vraiment que
lui il s'en fiché qui avait pas froid
mais qui aurait dû venir prendre le
train aussi des mineurs puis on aurait
vu qu'est-ce que c'était alors il dit
bon ben j'ai me débrouiller pour leur
avoir un autobus alors ils ont eu un
autobus après mais c'était pas mieux
parce que des fois bon elle était salé
mais c'est à l'hiver quand il y avait de
la neige alors là des fois il s'en
allaient alors au matin une bonne heure
et puis revenez encore plus tard dans
l'après-midi alors comme on nous a dit
bon ben
si vous voulez vous pouvez aller dans le
Nord là-bas Sabatier il y a du travail
mon Dieu on a du travail
vous n'avez pas la fin qui nous avait
dit ah il nous avait dit vous vos
enfants tout le monde aurait du travail
pour pour longtemps alors bon on a la
finalement qu'on a décidé de venir dans
le Nord et puis maintenant c'est le
contraire il a déjà plus de travail pour
sabotier alors les enfants ils finir
ensemble pas leur
dire sabotier parce que s'il y a plus de
travail après il va falloir qu'ils
partent au tarot aussi vous êtes arrivés
en quelle année ici
et
alors oui en ouvrant 54 et
après le quand on est arrivé d'ailleurs
mon Dieu c'était les maisons ils étaient
même pas fini
il y avait la trou devant le la porte il
fallait trouver le directeur tout de
suite pour qu'il vienne mettre des
terres on pouvait pas sortir de la
maison alors le tout de suite apporter
des terres pour boucher mais alors on
n'était pas bien venu par celui du Nord
vous savez quand les gens ils nous
aimaient pas parce qu'ils nous disait
qu'on était des boyaux rouges qu'on ait
manger leurs pâtes ou ça et
il nous a tapé des enfants qu'ils
allaient à l'école ils se faisaient
engueulé même par même par les parents
qui venaient chercher leurs enfants à
l'école quand on allait dans les
magasins on n'était pas versus on
pouvait pas y acheter vous voulez pas
nous vendre parce qu'on est du
Pas-de-Calais vous êtes beaucoup du
Pas-de-Calais maintenant oui maintenant
c'est tout d'ailleurs toute la nouvelle
cité j'ai même dans la veste c'est
beaucoup plus venu du Pas-de-Calais
il y en a même plus beaucoup d'une heure
parce que le bon quand on est arrivé
c'était déjà des
âgés du Nord alors maintenant
les tous les jeunes c'est du
Pas-de-Calais maintenant c'est on a plus
beaucoup du Nord vous étiez venu du
Pas-de-Calais parce que les mines
avaient fermé
où est-ce qu'on était non la mine elle
avait pas fermée mais commencez déjà
faire partir tout toutes les cités par
cité quoi dans les autres forces et
après aller fermer à la fermer
la première fois c'est la fermer c'était
la force sac puis après ils ont fermé
après la fossette alors les mineurs ils
allaient soit du côté de Lens n'importe
où quoi pourquoi vous disiez que vous
allez voler le pain des autres de ce de
ces disciples
il doutait que si on n'est pas ici
c'était pour premièrement le mari qui
travaillait puis après nos enfants
qu'ils auraient travaillé donc c'était
le du travail en moins pour les leurs
enfants parce que
moi je sais que quand on est arrivé ici
[Musique]
le fils de mineur alors il doit être
obligatoirement mignonne
on leur disait on dit quand même c'est
pas parce que le père qu'il est mineur
que le gosse il peut pas aller dans une
usine il dit non non il dit
vous irez faire embaucher votre gamme à
la mine et puis c'est tout parce que du
fait que le métier de mineur il reconnu
comme difficile et puis très dur et puis
insolubre j'ai préféré que mes fils qui
vont travailler dans une usine pour pas
qu'ils connaissent mon sort quoi parce
que malgré tout après t'entendre service
j'ai dû prendre ma retraite à cause de
la silicose j'ai eu 30% c'est l'école
c'est maintenant j'en ai 35 donc j'ai dû
arrêter de travailler et mes fils du
fait qu'ils n'ont pas trouvé de travail
ailleurs ils sont se sont embauché
eux-mêmes moi la mine donc
plus vous n'auriez pas voulu
parce que mais enfin
ça leur plaît il me ressort parce que
moi j'ai toujours aimé
[Musique]